last week it was announced that the
Auditors that's a company called
Johnston Carmichael had ceased working
for the SMP and it was only today when
Mr uh Mr Youssef was being quizzed by
journalists he was asked well when did
that happen and he revealed it was back
in October more than six months ago so
that has prompted accusations of a
cover-up and claims that the party has
hid the fact that the Auditors have uh
no longer working for the party for uh
six months now why has this happened
well Mr Youssef was asked that as well
he said I don't think I can release that
information he said I can see if
Johnston Carmichael uh will uh if we're
able to to do that to release it but uh
up to now the Auditors have said well we
adhere to client confidentiality we
don't discuss client business and so uh
this has prompted all sorts of questions
why did the order to stop working for
the party did they discover something
untoward are they whistleblers have they
were they was it they who tipped off the
police which led of course to the arrest
of Peter Murrell uh the former Chief
Executive husband of Nicholas sturgeon
last week now this is all to do with 600
000 pounds of missing money and a rather
unusual loan Arrangement Mr Murrell lent
the party some money a lot of unanswered
questions and political opponents have
seized on this as you might expect and
Jackie Bailey for example she's the
deputy leader of the labor party in
Scotland she's tweeted this the plot
continues to thicken that the SMP did
not come clean about this for months
stinks to High Heavens she went on to
say that um
that uh it's deeply worrying if they've
been unable to replace the orders in all
this time it's time for the secrecy to
end similar comments from Craig Hoy now
he's the chairman of the Tories in
Scotland he's an MSP this stenched
surrounding the snp's finances becomes
more toxic by the day so the clock is
ticking as Mr Youssef acknowledged today
by law the party has to submit his
accounts to the Electoral commission by
the 7th of July and uh if they don't do
that parties political parties can be
fined quite heavily for that and so he
has admitted it's going to be a real
challenge to get those accounts uh
approved in time so more questions
really not just for Mr Yousaf but for
Nicholas sturgeon as well as for Mr
Youssef well he was a member of Nicholas
sturgeon's cabinet before he became
party leader that was on the 27th of
March but he is claiming he knew nothing
about this until he became the leader of
the party just a few weeks ago